صناع السياسه في الولايات المتحده للبحث
عن شركاء اقوياء في مواجهه التحديات
العالميه واعتبر الكاتب ان الشركه الامثل
الذي يجب على امريكا ان تتعاون معه هو ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان مؤكدا
انه محفز بدوافع ايجابيه لخلق نهضه سعوديه
جديده الكاتب في مقاله ذكر بان فهم ما
يحفز ولي العهد السعودي يشكل نقطه البدايه
لكيفيه تعامل واشنطن مع قائد سيلعب دورا
مهما على المسرح العالمي لسنوات قادمه
المقال اختصر ما وصفه بالدوافع التي تحرك
الامير محمد بن سلمان بخمسه دوافع اولها
حبه وفخره بالسعوديه وشعبها بالاضافه الى
رغبته في ترك ارتيل لبلاده خصوصا في ظل ان
60% من السكان هم تحت سن الثلاثين من
الدوافع ايضا بحسب المقال رغبه ولي العهد
السعودي في جعل بلاده قوه للتغيير
الايجابي على الساحه العالميه
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الباحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
ايهاب مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذا المقال في واشنطن سبقه زياره
ولقاب لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن مع الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
السعودي لاي مدى هنا استشعرت هذه الاداره
الامريكيه اهميه علاقاتها مع السعوديه
وعلى وجه الخصوص مع ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان في خريطه سياستها
الخارجيه
سيدي ايهاب
طيب
اهلا بحضرتك استاذ نايف اعتذر
اهلا بالمشاهدين اسمح لي اضيف على ما قاله
الكاتب الايراني نقطه مهمه ايضا
اضافيه وهي ان
البعد المهم جدا الذي اضافه ايضا الامير
محمد بن سلمان هو رؤيته للاقليم واحداثه
من من الممكن ان تنتج عنه من
من الشر او خير للاقليم وبالتالي هذه
الرؤيه ايضا هي التي دعت واشنطن كي تتعامل
معه لانها تعلم انه لديه رؤيه مهمه ومحفزه
للاقليم في كافه المجالات اذا ما عدنا الى
الذي
يدعوا واشنطن لتغيير سياساتها اليوم
واشنطن في الواقع خسرت الكثير خلال
السنتين الماضيتين منذ تولي الرئيس جو
بايدن اداره الولايات المتحده كانت لديها
سياسات غير واضحه المملكه انا كنت اعتبرها
سياسات استفزازيه سياسات لا ترتقي لرؤيه
حليف وشريك قوي لشريكه الاخر وحليفه القوي
ايضا وبالتالي كانت علاقات متوتره في
البدايه ودائما اقول لدينا عامل ثابت في
هذه العلاقه وعامل متغير الثابت هو
المملكه العربيه السعوديه سياسه واضحه
قريبه فيها لا تحتاج الى اي تفسيرات
والعمل المتغير هو الاداره الامريكيه
اداره جو بايدن تاره اداره دونالد ترامب
تاره باراك اوباما الى اخره العامل
المتغير في علاقه مهمه كعلاقه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستكون دائما شيء لا يحمد عقبه
بمعنى ستؤخر الكثير من الامور المتعلقه
بالسياسات التي من المفترض ان تمارسها
واشنطن في المنطقه مع حلفائها وشركائها
وشاهدنا طبعا الاداره في بدايه العلاقه
عندما قام برفع مثلا جماعه الحوثيين من
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه بخلاف ما كان
وضعها قبل ذلك دونالد ترامب في هذه
القائمه واستمرار الهجمات وبعد ذلك قال
انه يدرس اعادتها عندما قامت بتكرار
هجماتها على اماكن مدنيه ونفطيه داخل
المملكه ولم يحدث اي شيء في هذا الاطار
ومع ذلك بقيت سياسه الرياض دائما سياسه
حكيمه ومتصقه مع اهدافها المحليه
يعني الكاتب قال بان الولايات المتحده لن
يكون لها صديق
وشريك نشط ايجابي وكذلك ايضا في كثير من
الملفات الدوليه العالقه وانت تعلم حاله
الانقسام وحاله الاستقطاب الشرقيه الغربيه
اليوم التي تخيم العالم قال لن يوجد لن
تجد الاداره الامريكيه شريكا على المسرح
العالمي افضل من التعامل مع ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ما الذي دفع
الكاتب برايك
لهذه الفكره
انا اعتقد طبعا الكاتب هو كاتب ايراني
معارض طبعا لايران ولديه رؤيه معينه لمن
هي الدول التي من الممكن ان تشكل الشراكه
الاهم للولايات المتحده خلال الفتره
القادمه وهو طبعا كاتب امريكي ايضا
فبالتالي هو يعتقد من وجهه نظره ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بما تتمتع به من
استقرار سياسي واقتصادي وعلاقات طيبه مع
كافه الاطراف على مستوى العالم علاقاتها
قويه مع روسيا علاقاتها قويه مع امريكا
علاقتها قويه مع الصين علاقاتها قويه مع
اوروبا ومع محيطها الاقليمي فليس هناك
افضل من مثل هذه التركيبه لاي دوله من
الدول كي تكون دوله قائده ورائده فعندما
تريد واشنطن ان يكون لديها علاقات قويه مع
مثل هذا النوع من الدول يجب ان تقدم
واشنطن ما يستدعي بالفعل ان تكون هذه
العلاقه قويه وبالتالي يجب ان تكون علاقه
شراكه وعلاقه تحالف بعد ذلك وانا اعتقد ان
العلاقه العلاقه ليست شراكه فقط هي شراكه
وتحالف ايضا ولكن هناك بعض المناقصات التي
تاتي تاره هنا وهناك بسبب اختلاف الادارات
وايدولوجيه الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
كله منهما لديه رؤيه مختلفه لكن يجب ان
يكون هناك دائما عوامل ثابته في هذه
العلاقه لا تتغير
وهذا هو ما تحدثت عنه العامل الثابت لدى
المملكه والمتغير لدى واشنطن الذي يؤدي
الى سياسات المتذبذب التي نشاهد احد
الدوافع الخمسه كانت هي
الحب وفخر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وشعبها بالامير محمد بن سلمان كما قال في
مقاله قال هذا الاعجاب يعبر عن غالب
المجتمع سواء تحدثت مع السعوديين في احد
الاحياء القديمه او حتى مع سائق احد
التطبيقات او الفنانين السعوديين قال لا
يملكون لا يملكون سوى الثناء والحب لهذا
القائد لقد اصبحت الرساله واضحه تتعامل
واشنطن مع زعيم شعبي ط ور علاقه عميقه مع
امته الشابه الاداره الامريكيه هل يتغير
تعاملها مع اي قائد اليوم السياسي
بحالته الشعبيه او بزعامته الشعبيه ايضا
كذلك سيدي ايهاب
والله شوفوا استاذ نايف ليس فقط السعوديين
داخل المملكه ولكن حتى السعوديين الذين
يعيشون بصفه دائمه ومستمره هنا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتقيت عدد
منهم هم ايضا فخورون بما يقدمه الامير
محمد بن سلمان ويعتقدون ان ذلك يقود
البلاد في الاتجاه الصحيح والتطور السريع
وهو ما نلاحظه جميعا في الواقع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشاهد عن كثب
مدى ارتباط الشعب السعودي بالتطورات التي
قدمها لهم ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن
سلمان خلال السنوات الماضيه ويعلمون انه
كلما كان هناك تقارب بين
الشعب والحاكم كلما كان هناك توحد في
الرؤيا وفي الفكره
وفناء في العمل ورغبه في التطور والنظر
الى الامام واشنطن بكل تاكيد يعني وانا
اكررنا دائما في مقابلاتي ستخسر كثيرا اذا
ما حا ان تعبث بهذه العلاقه التي تم العبث
بها بالفعل خلال السنتين الماضيين
الماضيتين لكن اليوم مع عوده العلاقات
بالشكل للمسار الطبيعي اعتقد انها من
الممكن ان تنطلق الى الامام بشكل ممتاز
اشكرك جزيل الشكر الباحث في الشؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات